all right guys bang bang Darius I
thought a great thing for us to talk
about today would be the debt ceiling
they everyone knows that it's coming but
no one really knows what the hell is
going on I know that at 42 macro you
guys have done a bunch of research
around this let's maybe just start with
the money market and the debt ceiling
kind of how these two things are
intersecting yeah 100 man so there's a
lot going on always great to be back on
your show man uh so we'll start with the
death ceiling right now we have some
really weird interesting kinks in the
money market curves uh what I mean money
money market specifically t-bill yields
over the last couple of weeks we've seen
the one month TBO yield which is kind of
right around D-Day as it relates to when
the government is likely to run out of
its funds that yield is backed up over
200 basis points in like two weeks so it
went from like 340 on the one month T
Bill to about 5 40 and it's it's heading
higher and so that's clearly an
indication of money market investors
getting just basically just saying I
don't want anyone anything to do with
this because obviously if the US
government defaults we're going to have
quite a big issue on our hands as
relation money market funds breaking the
buck things of that nature
when we go back and look at 2011 I know
you guys did this case study and so one
of the pieces of the current debt crisis
is uncertainty there's chaos that
there's fear-mongering there's uh
optimism like there's all these emotions
and feelings but at the end of the day
no one has a crystal ball no one knows
what's actually going to happen we have
to look to history for some sort of
guide in these past situations 2011 uh
you guys did the case study what did you
find when you did that
Yeah man so it's not a case study I was
trading markets back then I definitely
remember this uh very loud and clear uh
so this is one of the biggest lessons
that I learned in my career that's been
very beneficial throughout my career
which is asset markets are the conduit
from investors in the real economy
student politicians down in DC whether
they be Federal Reserve officials
whether it be members of Congress or
members of the White House and so what I
learned from that particular experience
is that when you have an impasse or a
stalemate down in DC you know I like to
call it Kabuki theater particularly with
respect to this debt selling issue
because it always eventually gets uh
extended
you almost need the crisis in the
markets to bring both sides closer
together at the negotiating table right
now you know speaker McCarthy's very
much dug in in terms of calling for you
know sequestration and cuts on on
mandatory spending programs Etc
obviously Biden's dug in with respect to
his agenda and the Democrats uh
willingness to the unwillingness to pass
the debt selling with any uh
contingencies and so it's ultimately the
closer we get to that scenario again
Jenny Ellen's outline June 1st as that
D-Day for potential um default uh it
might be a little bit longer might be a
little bit shorter no one really knows
but the closer we get to that moment and
the less and the likelihood that we
don't have a deal in place the more
likely it is asset markets start to sell
off in a medium material way to get to
that to get to bring both sides closer
together nothing focuses the mind like a
hanging right and that's ultimately what
we might see you saw the s p decline
about 17 in like two weeks going back to
that uh that Late July early August 11
experience before we move on to other
topics should we be worried about the
debt ceiling and do you think that the
US is actually going to default
uh so no uh no no this is this is Kabuki
theater uh it's very expensive Kabuki
theater depending on when and what when
and what I set you buy ahead of it uh
but I think you should be worried about
the Dell selling for a completely
different reason which is the US
government has not been issuing debt on
a net basis for several for a couple
quarters now and so Uncle Sam or as I
like to call the schoolyard Broly you
know at the top of the global capital
structure really has not been draining
liquidity from asset markets really for
a couple of quarters as a function of
this you know kind of hitting the
statutory debt limit so you know what
we've really been seeing is just kind of
constant rolling over and churning of
t-bill yields but I think what's just as
important is that because there has not
been much net coupon Supply in recent
quarters quantitative tightening has
really lost its teeth you know we're not
seeing the decline in Bank Reserves
associated with quantitative tightening
because we're not necessarily seeing
incremental um on coupon debt uh being
issued by the treasury that will change
at some point in the next Call of four
to six weeks because regardless of
whether they and legislate a legitimate
debt selling increase or they just punt
it into the future we know that Uncle
Sam's going to come back to the market
with some coupon issuance which would
make quantitative tightening a little
bit more onerous than it has been in
recent months so we know that the U.S
obviously does not operate in a vacuum
it is part of the global kind of
economic system let's go to the other
side of the world China I know that you
guys have been paying a lot of attention
to what's going on in China let's start
maybe with headline CPI year over year
for China and other Emerging Markets uh
around the world yeah absolutely so in
this chart where we show um headlines to
be on the left and core CPI on the right
we're showing them on a on a deviation
basis on a z-score basis relative to
their trailing 10-year means and what I
wanted to call out on this China's chart
is that we're going to get China CPI on
Thursday this morning we got overnight
we got the Chinese trade data for the
month of April and we saw import growth
slow pretty sharply to down eight
percent on a year-of-year basis crude
oil and ports crashing et cetera this in
our opinion is kind of the big risk as
it relates to kind of some of the
broader narratives out there around go
Global you know globally synchronized
recovery coming out of China Asia Europe
that's obviously kind of coming under
question and what may actually be a
silver lining in this sort of you know
kind of um you know reduced Chinese
demand Outlook is the fact that the pboc
might actually come be coming back to
the market uh with some pretty
aggressive balance sheet expansion and
so what we show on this uh the next
chart chart four are the balance sheets
for the ECB the bank of England the bank
of Japan the pboc and the Swiss National
Bank and so we'll focus your attention
on the blj and the pboc curves which are
the black line and the red lines in that
curse those two central banks where you
go back and you look at the bottom that
we saw in global liquidity uh vis-a-vis
Central Bank liquidity Etc in the latter
part of 2022 those two central banks are
really in charge of or really of the
biggest outsized contributors to the
uptick that we saw in global liquidity
if you go back and you look at this on a
three-month impulse basis which tends to
be the kind of the duration that
corresponds or correlates most asset
markets you know the BBC boj's balance
sheet peaked at plus 953 billion on a
trailing through month impulse basis in
January that number is now minus 197
billion uh through April the PBS or the
pboc's balance sheet which I think is as
important as it relates to the CBI data
we're going to get on Thursday is the it
peaked at plus 788 billion in January
and that number's all the way down to
plus 88 billion uh in the most recent
month and so in our opinion we've seen
kind of global liquidity stall out in
the past couple of months that's the
next chart there where we kind of show
the three different factors in our
Global liquidity proxy model whether it
be the Central Bank mobile central bank
balance sheet Global narrow money supply
and Global FX reserves X gold all three
of those indicators is sort of kind of
like peaked in January and February and
have rolled over pretty materially since
if you look at the global central bank
balance sheet it was plus 1.4 trillion
on a trillion three-month basis in
January that number is minus 254 billion
in April Global narrow money Supply Plus
2.2 trillion on a trillion three-month
basis in January that number's all the
way down at minus 848 billion in April
and then the global FX preserves plus
439 billion peaked in February on
impulse basis and is since slowed to
plus 63 billion untrilling through my
bases in April and so we're seeing kind
of that tidal wave of global liquidity
that's been very positive for Bitcoin
very positive for kind of you know long
duration assets throughout the year to
date it's very much started to wane and
it's very much started to wane and so
one thing that may be positive the
Silver Lining that's coming out of this
China slowdown or not slow down it's
just disappointment and in the Chinese
economy you may actually get the pboc
back engaged in terms of expanding its
balance sheet again how much of the
central banks are mirroring each other
versus some are chasing the us or the US
is chasing other central banks like how
do you think about the relationship
between them yeah no phenomenal question
man so um with respect to the the the
the English um another English the
European uh central bank balance sheets
they are very much lagging the FED with
respect to their policy we got uh the
ECB uh most recent policy decision last
Thursday post the FED they hiked
interest rates they slowed the pace of
the interest rate hikes but they also
outlined that they're going to be um
implementing um a faster balance sheet
expansion uh starting in July with sorry
faster balance sheet contraction started
in July so they're kind of just lagging
the fed by a couple of quarters as it
relates to uh to their reaction function
same thing with the bank of England
we're going to get their uh policy
update uh in the month and for for
Thursday and they're very much kind of
lagging both the ECB and the FED Swiss
National Bank bank Japan on pboj or pboc
are all kind of in a different boat you
know these are these balance sheets are
in a very much different boat because
they are sort of fighting the kind of
traditional balance sheet beggar Thy
Neighbor War which is down dollar means
our currencies go up we're predominantly
export-oriented economies which means if
I allow my currency to appreciate versus
the dollar more so then you know you uh
your Japanese Yen or if I'm the Japanese
Yen then you uh Swiss franc or find the
Swiss franc you you know Chinese won
then that's going to obviously hurt uh
um you know the relative demand for
their goods and their services and so
what tends to happen when you're in
these periods of declining US dollars or
declining dollar values you tend to see
those kinds of central banks really
start to step on the gas to kind of
limit the appreciation that we're seeing
in their currencies and and thus far the
the Chinese um Chinese authorities have
been the most effective in causing you
know kind of a reversal and flows from
their economy the last chart that you
have here is global liquidity S P 500
and Bitcoin which are obviously various
uh types of assets across kind of the
global world what is this telling us
yeah absolutely so as I mentioned uh our
Global liquidity proxy just amalgamates
the global central bank balance sheet
Global narrow money supply and Global FX
reserves X gold for obvious reasons
Global central bank balance sheet
contributes to global liquidity Global
narrow money supply central banks aren't
the only entities that create liquidity
obviously commercial Banks create
liquidity as well and then you also have
to look at liquidity that's being
created uh through the growth of FX
reserves because again that's that
process of you know pboc boj et cetera
defending their currencies against um
you know dollar devaluation and so when
you amalgamate all three of those
instruments you know we saw a global
liquidity Peak at plus 3.9 trillion on a
trailing three-month basis in January
it's since rolled over to minus 1
trillion in April so it's not as
negative as it had been throughout most
of 2022 but it certainly start to be
negative a little bit at the margins in
recent months and the reason I call that
out is not to scare anyone it's not
particularly that negative on an
absolute basis but what I will call out
in that chart is if we're showing in the
bottom panels each of those indicators
the global liquidity proxy um the SB of
100 and Bitcoin on a trailing one year
z-score basis and what we see is this
z-score for uh for the global fire
Global liquidity proxy is somewhere
right around minus 0.3 or 0.4 whereas
these who are for the s p and Bitcoin
are right around plus 1.2 plus 1.3 and
so it's telling you that assets have
kind of run up farther faster than what
is implied by global liquidity now
that's that's totally fine you can have
these kind of deviations you know for
several months at a time but generally
speaking they prob they generally are do
trade um you know kind of in line with
each other and if anything the global
liquidity proxy tends to be a leading
indicator for things like the s p and
Bitcoin and so the one thing I will say
is that you know asset markets may have
gotten over their ski tips a little bit
and in the context of this debt selling
which may require asset markets being
the conduit to pull these guys closer
together from a negotiating standpoint
and also the return of coupon issuance
on the other side of this debt selling
increase you could be heading for a
period of kind of Rocky you know
volatile asset markets over the next you
know let's call it a month or two are
you making any changes to your portfolio
based on all this information
uh no so we run a very systematic um
portfolio construction process at 42
macro I have a lot of thoughts I have a
lot of views but ultimately those
thoughts and those views get filtered
through our weather model system our
volatility just a momentum signals in
order to sort of guide the pivots that
are boiler formula construction is
making the one thing I would call out is
that that systematic process is
currently a 51 cash and so if I can if
that's if there's a signal there I think
that's certainly um one of the bigger
signals uh in the um in the process yeah
I think that uh being systematic in
times of uncertainty ends up being uh
being pretty good Darius where can we
send people to find you on the internet
or find out more about 42 macro
absolutely man thanks for joining us on
and we'll catch back around next time so
we're at 42macro.com and 42 macro
weather is our Twitter account we also
have a private Twitter for 42 micro
subscribers at 42 macro where appreciate
you for having us man I I always
appreciate I always learn so much from
you guys if anyone hasn't checked out 42
macro at this point they must be
sleeping uh but uh thank you so much for
putting in charge under a very
comfortable Rock
the biggest doing a great job so I
appreciate you coming on educating us uh
every week or so and I will definitely
do this again in the future
absolutely brother that catching that
section next time